[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american teen comedy
film called
bully
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
jimmy mulligan is a polite teenager in
high school in the opening scene we see
him minding his own business in the
school's hallway a trio of bullies eddie
neil and their leader miles walk down
the hallway intimidating everyone on
their way miles shoves the books out of
jimmy's hands and challenges him to do
something about it as usual jimmy lets
them walk over him and does nothing
since he never retaliates the bullies
often target him later jimmy is
approached by his only friends andy and
bobby both of whom are considered the
school's losers over time the constant
nagging and insulting have made jimmy
depressed his mother senses something is
wrong but jimmy refuses to tell her what
he's going through after school his
friends call him over to lighten the
mood but jimmy refuses to go he knows
that there is a chance he will bump into
miles who also lives in the same
neighborhood hence he dreads leaving the
house all together the next day at
school andy and bobby greet him using
popular teenage slang to sound cool but
fail miserably jimmy feels at home with
them that is until miles approaches him
yet again bobby runs away immediately
knowing that the guy will definitely
insult him miles stops the other two and
asks jimmy for a hundred dollars when
jimmy claims that he doesn't owe them
anything the guy starts getting
aggressive but then miles notices vinnie
watching them and retreats for a moment
vinny is a great fighter who has many
dangerous connections he doesn't like
when miles and his group bother people
and is always keeping an eye on them
because of his influence even the
bullies are scared of him then we are
introduced to a girl named adrian she is
smart and friendly but is always
misjudged by her looks she seems to have
a crush on jimmy but he doesn't believe
any girl would be interested in him one
of the bullies named eddie touches bobby
inappropriately in class causing him to
scream and run away because bobby likes
men the bullies call him slurs and make
fun of him all the time jimmy helps his
friend feel better before the guys go to
the cafeteria they notice adrian staring
at jimmy but he is still not convinced
that she is interested in him miles sits
with the group and asks him for money
yet again this time a senior guy stands
up against the bully not wanting to get
into trouble miles leaves but it doesn't
take him long before approaching jimmy
again he stops jimmy on his way home
furious about what happened at the
cafeteria when jimmy refuses to pay the
bully starts beating him up a neighbor
named mr jackson notices this and comes
out to save jimmy miles calls him a
racial slur before driving away with his
friend after that jackson brings jimmy
inside and helps him with his injuries
jimmy notices a picture of a boxer on
the wall and is surprised to find out
the person is jackson it turns out that
he used to be a national boxer back in
the day he suggests that jimmy learns
self-defense so the guys won't bother
him again but jimmy doesn't even know
where to begin a while later jackson
takes him home where his parents are
horrified to see their son with a black
eye jackson tells them what happened and
brings up the topic of self-defense
class the parents seem skeptical and ask
for some time to think it over in the
following scene someone knocks on
jackson's door he opens it to see the
couple with jimmy who now has two black
eyes they hand their son over to jackson
requesting him to make the kid tough
however jackson doesn't train guys
himself he has a friend named manny who
runs a gym and a boxing center when
jimmy walks into the establishment for
the first time he feels out of place he
doesn't know if he will survive between
the athletic and muscular people with
his body type still manny takes him in
and encourages him saying that nothing
is impossible if he puts his heart into
the training he is sure to learn the
basics of boxing in no time to boost his
confidence manny makes him show his
strength and is pleasantly surprised
when he is strong enough to push him
jimmy then gears up and practices for
two full hours before returning home
with jackson by the end of the day he is
tired to the core but jackson notices
that he's worried about something else
upon being asked jimmy reveals that the
bullies are not going to stop bothering
him until he gives them the money but to
teach them a lesson he will have to
train for at least a month after
thinking about it for a while jackson
comes up with a solution he advises
jimmy to promise them 200
if they wait for a month that way their
greedy asses will fall right into the
trap and wait for the day until he is
ready to beat them the next morning
jimmy can barely move every muscle in
his body hurts which makes him want to
give up right then and there his mother
gives him a half-filled pain relief
ointment that wouldn't be enough for a
single arm still he somehow gets dressed
for the day and goes to school andy
meets him on the way and sees him
waddling because of the pain in his
thighs jimmy refrains from telling his
friend the truth afraid that he won't
commit to boxing at school the bullies
approach him in the hallways as always
they slam him into the lockers for the
money but jimmy is quick to divert their
attention he claims to have gotten a
very good after-school job that will pay
him after a month if they wait for that
long he promises to double the money
miles and the group agree before making
him understand if he is unable to keep
his word the consequences will not be
good for the next few days jimmy has a
very hard time training because he is
not habituated to a lot of physical
exercises the pressure is just too much
for him his exhaustion is clearly
visible in his performance one day manny
tells jackson that if the kid doesn't
show progress he will have to join
another gym because he is not fond of
laziness in his establishment that night
on their way back home jimmy reveals
that he doesn't feel confident in his
strength after all the hard work he is
still not sure if he'll be able to beat
the bullies but after jackson shares his
own experience and the experience of his
fellow boxers jimmy is motivated with
the will to try harder the next day he
doesn't wait for jackson to pick him up
and instead cycles to the gym so he can
warm up even his performance is much
better which surprises manny day by day
he builds up his core strength and
doesn't get sore after the practices
anymore both manny and jackson are
impressed by his determination in
addition to this he is much more
confident while talking to the bullies
at school but is careful not to anger
them one day during the lunch break andy
brings up the topic of adrien jimmy
comments that he would love to date her
she overhears him saying that and sits
by him that evening she and her mother
come to pick him up for a high school
party jimmy's parents are shocked since
he has never had a girl over before the
experience is emotional for them because
they had basically given up on their son
dating anyone at the party the host
makes inappropriate comments about the
couple in an empty room they feel
uncomfortable and come to the front yard
to spend time privately adrian notices
that jimmy has lost a few pounds over
the past couple of weeks and asks him
what his secret is jimmy asks her to be
ready after school tomorrow planning to
take her to the gym the two fall into
silence before leaning in for a kiss the
moment is interrupted though when
miles's minion starts insulting the
couple jimmy takes a stand for himself
and orders the guy to go away because he
is without his group the guy has no
choice but to oblige this makes jimmy
realize that they only targeted him
because he never fought back the
following day jackson picks up jimmy and
adrian initially he is thrown off by
adrian's appearance but after talking to
her on the way to the gym he figures she
is a sweet girl when adrian finds out
that jimmy trains in boxing she is taken
aback she wishes to be like the trainees
in the gym but is skeptical that being a
girl doesn't go with boxing to prove her
wrong manny makes his best female
athlete box against his best male
athlete she knocks him out showcasing
her skill and strength an impressed
adrian decides to join the gym and train
alongside jimmy she also sees manny go
against jimmy and is pleasantly
surprised by jimmy's skills the next day
is the weekend but jimmy is so
determined to get better that he doesn't
want to miss a single day of training he
meets an mma fighter who helps him learn
a few mma tips and tricks it has been
over a month since jimmy made the
promise to the bullies miles loses his
patience and orders jimmy to bring the
money after school if miles doesn't
return home with the money today jimmy
won't return home at all
later in the bathroom jimmy meets vinnie
the guy who even the bullies are afraid
of vinnie happens to know that he is
training at the gym nowadays he predicts
that jimmy is about to challenge miles
to a fight and wishes him luck after
they leave we see that one of miles
minions was inside a stall the entire
time he immediately texts his leader and
tells him everything he heard miles is
enraged someone who he had thought was
completely submissive is going as far as
to challenge him to a fight if jimmy
wins this one the reputation he has
created for himself will go downhill
hence he calls one of his adult
associates named billy for help billy is
willing to do anything for money and has
recently come out of jail jimmy is sure
to be defeated if he goes against a
professional like billy hence miles is
not worried about the fight but
unbeknownst to him vinny has found out
about his little plan to sabotage a fair
fight he in turn pulls some strengths
and makes sure that billy won't make it
to the school grounds a worried adrian
calls manny and tells him that something
feels off manny has full confidence in
his training and assures her that jimmy
can handle any high school bully school
finally ends for the day and a crowd
gathers outside to witness the fight
billy is on his way to the school when
two people abduct him at vinnie's
request meanwhile miles boasts about how
he is about to beat jimmy to a pulp
knowing that jimmy isn't weak vinnie
encourages him to go one on one with him
the fight starts and initially miles
lands a punch before jimmy but when
jimmy's anger erupts miles is beaten to
the ground everyone is shocked including
the teachers who are watching them from
the staff room's window jimmy tells
miles to never trouble anyone at the
school again before knocking him out
adrian runs to him for a hug as the
crowd erupts into cheers someone uploads
the video of the fight on the internet
and it gains millions of likes people
praise jimmy for standing up against
bullying and it becomes a lesson for
everyone who picks on weaker people for
fun subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching